[Musique]
harry salomon bonjour bonjour et bonjour
à tous les auditeurs et à tous les
artisans vous êtes le président donc de
la chambre de métiers de la martinique
et vous organisez ce soir en partenariat
avec l'ademe une conférence sur
l'économie circulaire quelle est la
définition de l'économie circulaire
alors l'économie circulaire c'est une
économie donc responsable
traditionnellement on a toujours utilisé
des matières premières produits donc
créer des produits
on les a commercialisé et ensuite tous
les déchets à l'est soit dans la nature
soit dans les décharges les communes et
l'économie circulaire c'est réduire
l'impact sur l'environnement
c'est à dire mieux préserver les
matières premières transformés les
produits dont créer de nouveaux produits
de façon plus intelligente plus éco
responsable et surtout créer moins de
déchets et créer moins de déchets ça
veut dire aussi recycler les déchets
produits pour pouvoir attaquer pu servir
à d'autres choses
en fait les déchets des uns peuvent être
les matières premières des autres
s'il ya vraiment une intelligence de
production montre bien il faut donc
prendre en compte l'environnement gérer
très bien traiter ses déchets et avoir
aussi utilisé à bon escient la ressource
afin d'éviter lac de l'aigle gaspillage
absolument aujourd'hui donc on peut
faire le constat nous avons beaucoup de
marchandises qui sont importées sur le
territoire de la martinique à toutes ces
marchandises importées donc ça fait des
déchets qui s'accumulent alors
aujourd'hui il faut se former par vers
une consommation plus intelligente c'est
à dire lorsque les produits sont
réalisés créé et produit en martinique
ça veut dire que déjà ça va créer de
l'emploi localement
ça va aussi éviter de faire venir des
matières premières ou d'accumuler des
déchets qui viennent de l'extérieur ça
va donc préserver notre environnement
mais surtout préserver notre économie et
dans le cadre de l'artisanat mme donc
qui est vraiment donc
des instruments de la production locale
ça permet de faire vivre des entreprises
artisanales donc de créer de l'emploi en
martinique
c'est la question que j'allais vous pas
vous poser pourquoi la chambre de meech
et satire est elle à l'économie
circulaire cela veut dire que les
artisans sont plus touchés sont éco
responsable que tous les autres que
toutes les autres professions ou pas du
tout au contraire ils sont plus éco
responsable je vous ai parlé de
production locale en fait quand vous
faites venir de la marchandise importée
donc vous l'a fait voyager en avion vous
l'a fait voyager en bateau
parfois on puise dans les ressources de
certains pays et voir même dans les
ressources humaines de certains pays
défavorisés eh bien ça ce n'est pas
éco-responsable lorsque l'on produit ici
il ya des choses que l'on peut produire
en martinique
mais là on a un comportement éco
responsable en tant que producteur donc
en tant qu'artisans en tant
qu'industriel aussi puisque l'économie
circulaire sein concerne les artisans
mais aussi l'industrie locale
l'agriculture locale aussi et bien
lorsqu'on à ces comportements
responsables a déjà un impact man la
nature mais surtout en créer des
activités donc aux multiples les
activités pour nos entreprises locales
alors qu'on comprenne bien par exemple
je fais venir tels telle marchandise
j'ai dû j'ai des cartes ont donc quitté
emballer un artisan 36 cartons
transforme ses cartes en meubles est-ce
qu'on est dedans de l'économie
circulaire par exemple absolument là
vous avez vu que les déchets des uns
peuvent servir de matière première aux
autres et bien là donc ces cartons et
d'ailleurs il ya une semaine j'étais sur
un salon de l'artisanat d'art il y avait
une artisane qui à partir de carton
réalisé des lampadaires réaliser des
objets de décoration des vases et tous à
partir de carton et de papier mâché qui
avait été recyclés il ya des artisans
d'art aussi qu'ils vont utiliser le vert
qui nous a servi pour pour les
bouteilles un mât qui vont le fondre qui
vont le traité et qui vont créer des
objets d'art qui vont pouvoir être
utilisées donc pour des lampadaires pour
de la décoration pour des oeuvres d'art
plan pourra même exporté donc ça vous
voyez que le recyclage l1 peut générer
des richesses au pays
et c'est la voie que nous avons
yport la chambre de métiers d'abord
parce que l'artisanat d'art l'artisanat
en général c'est là c'est surtout de la
production locale
donc mon travail sur le pays sur notre
territoire on recycle aussi des
marchandises éco-responsable ça veut
dire aussi que ce qui est produit doit
pouvoir être préparé et ça c'est un
écran en problème un jeu pour crois
qu'on a tous connu on achète des objets
au bout de quatre ans cinq ans parfois
moins ils sont ils deviennent obsolètes
irréparable et bien à une économie éco
responsable le sens pogroms meilleurs
voilà il faut pouvoir réparer ces
produits et qui dit réparation de
produits c'est de l'artisanat ça veut
dire que certaines personnes certains
jeunes vont pouvoir se former pour
réparer pour entretenir donner une
nouvelle vie donc on fait des économies
et en impact - notre environnement
alors qu'est ce que ça représente en
martinique que l'économie circulaire en
termes d' entreprises en termes d'action
en termes de chiffre d'affaires
alors les dix mille entreprises de la
chambre de métiers sont concernés mais
je vous ai parlé aussi de l'industrie
donc l'industrie aussi est concerné
l'agriculture donc c'est vraiment donc
selon s'ils semblent le dire de notre
économie qui est concerné par les co
responsables et même pour ceux qui
importent des marchandises il faut aussi
qu'ils net attitude éco responsable
c'est à dire on importe
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des déchets
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des emballages
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des produits
lorsqu'ils seront usagers parce que nous
avons une belle martinique
c'est aussi notre richesse notre
tourisme s'appuie sur la qualité de vie
à la martinique
et bien si notre martinique est polluée
nous allons perdre donc une partie de
nos ressources
vous allez mettre en place une sorte de
labellisation une sorte de liste des
entreprises éco-responsables
absolument par exemple dans le cadre de
l'automobile
donc nous avons créé un label garage
propres ça veut dire que les artisans
donc des réparateurs automobiles qui ont
ce label ont suivi une démarche par
exemple pour le traitement de leurs
déchets
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des pièces de
carrosserie des pièces de moteur qui
sont usagés il faut qu'elle soit traitée
acheminés pour pouvoir être recyclés
voir réutiliser ou détruits dans de
bonnes conditions
pareil pour les huiles usagées rien de
pire que des huiles qui
on à l'abandon dans la nature qui
polluent de façon durable nous autorise
wierre notre littoral est bien là aussi
donc c'est garage ils s'engagent à
récupérer les îles les huiles pour
pouvoir les faire recycler et ça donc ce
sont des actes positifs pour l'économie
ce sont aussi des investissements
comment faire ses artisans donc il faut
qu'ils puissent être identifiés
labellisé et bien sûr donc là nous
travaillons sur la labellisation
mais il faudra aussi que l'on puisse
avoir des contrôles sévères pour ceux
qui ne respectent pas donc là notre
environnement qui ne respectent pas les
règles du jeu à ce qu'il ya une loi donc
sur la transition énergétique qui nous
impose aujourd'hui est bien de mieux
faire de bien faire et surtout de ne pas
gaspiller avec des sanctions à la clé
évidemment vous parlez de la loi sur la
transition énergétique qui a une plaie
qui touche aussi la martinique se sont
divisés oui bah tous ces véhicules il
faudrait qu'ils puissent être démonté et
recyclé et ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya
une filière la cuvée ça veut dire aussi
qu'il faut qu'il ait une volonté donc
politique pour pouvoir mettre en place
une filière avec bien sûr des sanctions
pour les contrevenants mais que pour le
citoyen ce soit très facile et bien de
se débarrasser de son véhicule parce que
non seulement c'est pas beau ça pou lui
il ya des îles qui traîne et puis ce
sont aussi des facteurs de développement
des moustiques l'économie responsable
donc l'économie circulaire économie
intelligente c'est vraiment plus que
nécessaire dans le petit territoire
comme la martinique
mais l'économie responsable si on crée
une filière par exemple pour l'hévéa chu
doit s'intégrer dès la conception du
projet c'est à dire que on ne crée pas
la filière et ensuite on y pense environ
ça on ajoute ensuite
mais c'est dès la conception du projet
qu'on doit déjà penser l'économie
circulaire mais c'est donc la tendance
du moment et c'est cadré par des lois
aujourd'hui tous les industriels pour
répondre à des normes européennes
doivent penser déjà à ce que vont
devenir donc leurs produits une fois
qu'ils seront en fin de vie comment ils
vont être et bien détruit stocker
réutiliser transformé pour ne pas
polluer l'environnement
ce que les chefs d'entreprise
prêt à ça ils ont honte honte comme
créer une société ce qu'ils ont déjà été
gris cela il faut les former encore
alors je vais vous parler des artisans
les artisans sont prêts à ça parce que
ça représente une plus-value c'est à
dire quand on dit on va acheter local
amiens on va acheter déjà donc
responsable donc c'est une plus value
pour l'artisan pour l'artisanat en
général et c'est aussi une plus value
pour le client puisque il va faire un
achat donc éco responsable à l'achat
donc qui va permettre d'alimenter le
pays de faire vivre le pays sans le
détruire
justement vous parlez du client parce
qu'on a on a on a parlé des
entrepreneurs des des artisans mais il
ya aussi le client c'est l'icône me
circulaire l'îlot client doit le
consommateur a aussi sa place
comment l'informer comment le
sensibiliser et bien je suis là pour ça
ce matin justement pour dire que tous
les martiniquais c'est consommer local
c'est consommer éco responsable lorsque
vous achetez des produits qui sont
réalisés en martinique vous fait vivre
des martiniquais en plus vous favorisez
le rajeunissement de la population parce
que si on ne produit plus qu'est-ce qui
se passe
ce qu'on voit actuellement les jeunes
vont à l'extérieur pour se former pour
travailler et le pays vit et bien un
acte de consommation éco-responsable un
acte de consommation intelligente c'est
se dire je vais acheter un produit qui
enrichit mon pays donc leurs produits de
l'artisanat local
un produit de l'agriculture locale un
produit de l'industrie locale et nous
nous sommes donc nous travaillons avec
des normes ça veut dire que nos produits
ils sont produits réalisés dans de
bonnes conditions
ce qui n'est pas le cas de certains
produits importés qui viennent de
l'autre bout du monde où on ne pense
qu'au prix on enrichit certaines
personnes à l'international et en fait
on appauvrit notre pays en termes de
perspectives dont on parlera du prix si
on a encore le temps en termes de
perspectives c'est ce que ça peut
générer
des emplois si oui quel type d'emploi
dans quels secteurs absolument déjà donc
les produits de la transformation ont
fait on fait des produits on peut très
bien les réutiliser pour autre chose
ce moment la réparation il ya beaucoup
de produits et que ce soit dans
l'électronique dans la mécanique dans le
bois même dans la bijouterie qui peuvent
être réparés par des artisans
ce qui n'est pas possible avec les
produits donc industriels importés et
puis il ya le traitement des déchets de
très souvent ce sont des gens pour le
qualifier absolument aujourd'hui si vous
devez faire des réparations dans le
domaine mécanique ou électronique
il faut avoir une qualification et la
chambre de métiers là pour former les
artisans les orienter aussi vers les
pistes du futur en termes d'emplois et
l'économie circulaire en est une parce
que on a besoin de réparateurs on a
besoin de transformateurs on a besoin de
gens qui utilise intelligemment les
déchets et surtout on a besoin de
travail au pays en deux secondes
certes on veut consommer local éco
responsable mais il ya le problème du
prix bien le prix en fait si on ne
consomme pas et coresponsable ça va nous
coûter beaucoup plus cher plus tard
donc on dit bien bon marché qu'a coûté
cher et ça c'est une réalité économique
donc fait des économies
consommez local parce que vous avez
consommé bien pour longtemps oui salomon
je vous remercie je rappelle que la
conférence débat sur l'économie
circulaire a lieu ce soir à 18 heures à
la chambre de métiers
bonne journée sur notre antenne
[Musique]
etc